أجرى طيارو قيادة الضربة العالمية
إطلاقًا تجريبيًا تشغيليًا لصاروخ باليستي غير مسلح
من minuteman 3 في
11 أغسطس لإظهار استعداد
القوات النووية الأمريكية وتوفير
الثقة في مدى فتك
وفعالية الرادع النووي للأمة ،
حيث استخدم اختبار الإطلاق اليوم صاروخ
باليستي عابر للقارات تم اختياره عشوائيًا  تم سحب الصاروخ من المطارات الثقيلة التي
تتخذ من ولاية أيوا مقراً لها ، حيث
تم نقل الصاروخ لمسافة 300 ميل
وأعيد تجميعه في قاعدة فاندنبرغ للقوة الفضائية بكاليفورنيا.
في الساعة إلى
نطاق اختبار بالقرب من أداة cuatrolina في
جزر مارشال ، يساعد برنامج تقييم اختبار icbm في
التحقق من
موثوقية المظلة النووية التي
يعتمد عليها حلفاؤنا وشركاؤنا في
القضاء على الحاجة إلى الحصول على
أسلحتهم النووية لمواجهة الخصوم المحتملين الذين
يبلغون
من العمر 50 عامًا  مينيوتمان 3  يقع مقرها في
كولورادو مونتانا نبراسكا شمال
داكوتا وويومنغ وسيتم استبدالها
ببرنامج الردع الاستراتيجي الأرضي
لتسجيل
التقارير من فاندنبرغ فضاء القوة
الفضائية أنا مايكل ستونكيفير